all right great it's a lot of fun to
participate in this meeting it's
marvelous to hear about all this recent
data and I think especially what Lauren
talked about fits in well with some of
the stuff as he mentioned that mark
Brandon did in my lab a little while ago
so I added that into the middle of my
talk specifically because of that
connection but in general we've been
very interested in mechanisms for
episodic memory and the campus an
internal cortex and in particular as
you've already kind of heard coding of
episodic memory requires knowing the
location and the time of specific events
for the episode that's being stored and
so we're very interested in the
mechanisms for coding these the space
and time of events that seem to involve
circuits in internal cortex and
hippocampus and there seems to be
important roles of different inputs to
the internal cortex and as in the
mechanism for coding of space and time
so we've done work on the influence of
the medial septum on the internal cortex
but then there's also data that I'll
talk about at the end that implicate the
important role of cortical sensory input
coming into these regions from areas
such as retro spleen neocortex so here's
an overview first I'll talk about some
of these medial septal inputs which
connects with what people like Lauren
have talked about in terms of the
theater the role of the theta rhythm for
coding of the spatial representation and
grid cells as well as the coding of time
then I'll talk about the alternation
which we call theta theta cycle skipping
and then I'll talk about visual coding
so just to kind of give an intro for the
grid cells this is a movie of grid cell
recording from our lab as you know they
were grid cells were discovered in the
lab of Ed Barden Maybrick Moser with the
paradigm that's commonly used for
studying grid cells is to have a rat
foraging in an open field environment
and you can track its head direction and
location based on LEDs attached to the
head of the rat each time an individual
cell fires a spike obviously that video
has been sped up quite a bit
and you can get you get these responses
that are falling in a regular array of
locations in the environment falling on
the vertices of tightly packed
equilateral triangles now right up front
I want to mention that there is
interesting data implicating a role for
theta rhythm in grid cell firing we
don't fully know the mechanism of its
role in grid cell firing but I want to
emphasize that the Moser lab showed very
strong relationships of the spiking of
grid cells to the ongoing theta rhythm
in the n-terminal cortex and here's an
example that the cells show a phenomena
of theta phase recession where when the
rat first enters the firing field of a
grid cell the spikes occur at the end of
the theta phase in theta cycle and move
to earlier and earlier phases which is
very similar to this theta sequence
retrieval that lauren talked about and I
was from David's paper but David's
actually shown that they're actually
distinct you can have one without the
other
but you see this very clear phase
procession in each of the firing fields
and it's also been shown this as data
from that Jason climber did in my lab
where we had the rats running through
two dimensional firing fields and he
still saw theta phase procession four
grid cells I mean this connects with
theta we had a number of years ago from
mark Brandon showing that manipulations
that effect theta rhythm effect the
spatial periodicity of grid cells so he
had recordings of theta rhythm and the
baseline condition during recordings of
nice spatial periodicity and individual
internal grid cells and then he
performed inactivation of the medial
septum with the gab
agnus Musa mall and saw loss of the
theta periodicity and the loss of the
spatial periodicity the grid cells and
then as the theta frequency comes back
you see the regaining of the spatial
periodicity of the grid cells now in
addition in more recent work in
collaboration with Hart I can bombs lab
of mark brand encountered an Kraus and
in this collaboration showed that the
grid cells will also fire as time cells
which is a term that howard got acquired
so this shows an individual grid cells
above there is already characterized as
a in a two to two dimension open field
now it's being recorded as a rat runs on
a treadmill and you can see the satiric
for your period of time then it fires
for a period of time then it's silent
it'll fire at the end of the run right
and then you'll see it scarred another
trial little firing right at the
beginning stops there's again for a
period of time then stops virus again
for a period of time so this is
corresponding to something like this
it's a different cell but it's a
sensitive phenomena where the cells in
characterized as a grid cell in your
lair field and then on multiple
different trials of running on the
treadmill it fires at the beginning and
it stops firing then it fires again and
it stops firing then it fires again so
it's a very striking characteristic I
want to emphasize that these time cells
were initially described in hippocampus
but this is showing that the cells that
fire as grid cells will also fire as
time cells why are you saying time cells
and because I mean the the rat or the
mouse is still moving right so yeah so
that's actually so it's a good point and
I didn't have time I took out a lot of
slides that I normally show but we
actually did an experiment actually in
this paper that was Ben Kraus in 2013
where we specifically looked at
different treadmill speed so that we
could dissociate time of running from
distance of running on the treadmill and
it actually turns out that some cells
will code
tons of running but some cells will code
the time duration of the running so I
wish I still had that slide in there and
just to connect to the the data on grid
cells just as grid cells will lose their
spatial periodicity with medial septum
and active septum and activation IVA
postal Cova showed that time cells in
this case and hippocampus will lose
their time specificity during the medial
septum inactivation so here's a time
cell firing at one time and then
completely shuts off here's one that's
firing a couple of different times and
it keeps firing but loses its
specificity and here's a whole array of
different time cells and you can see
that they lose their temporal
specificity during the medial septum
inactivation so this is really exciting
in the sense that both the spatial
coding and the temporal coding seem to
involve similar mechanisms dependent on
the medial septum but we don't yet know
those mechanisms mechanisms there's a
number of inputs gavage at cholinergic
and we're still trying to differentiate
these different inputs from medial
septum now there's a number of models of
grid cells and I should say right up
front that actually all these models can
account for time cell type responses as
well so the there's the attractor
dynamic models of grid cells that can
integrate velocity speeding direction
but they can also if you assume there's
some kind of steady input they can also
give the movement through time there's
also the oscillatory interference models
which can very effectively as shown here
simulate the spatial periodicity of grid
cells but then also can very effectively
simulate the multiple firing fields that
I just showed you during the running on
a treadmill so both of these types of
models are potentially able to address
this data and I guess I really want to
emphasize these types of models because
we still haven't really resolved fully
the details of the mechanisms of these
models in particular one thing I
mentioned in this slide is that the
attractor models are consistent with a
lot of the data but they have not yet
simulated theta phase procession in
two-dimensional environments or in
temporal coding it's been shown in the
McNaughton lab that can do just one
dimensional environments so I think I
mean I think the dominant feeling in the
field is and I
and I agree with this the attractor
dynamics are important for grid cell
firing but we really have a number of
different questions that need to be
resolved particularly how you get this
theta phase coating and as I mentioned
here there's conflict between this model
and the fact that the data from bats
such as that gathered by Michael yartsev
doesn't show grid cells without theta
rhythmicity so that's a big question
mark for this model but moving on I want
to talk about the fact that both these
types of models integrate velocity for
generating the grid cell responses so
they use both direction and speed and
this is consistent with other types of
neuronal responses in the internal
cortex in particular their cells that
code running speed as animals are moving
around in an open field environment
these will change their firing rate with
the running speed of the animal and
there are neurons the code head
direction and regionally described by
Jim ronk and also by Jeff Howie so in
recent work that Jake Hanlon and mark
Brandon did in my laboratory we've
actually looked at these different types
of coding of running speed on a number
of different groups have shown
influences of running speed on the
firing properties of neurons in
particular all of the different cell
types in the internal cortex actually
will change their firing rate or at
least examples of them will change their
firing weight with the running speed of
the animal so grid cells conjunctive
grid by head Direction cells head
Direction cells and then what the crop
paper from the Moser lab called speed
cells which are cells they're usually
inter neurons that didn't have any other
kind of functional coding but show very
clear coding of running speed but in
this paper we were focusing on the fact
that an additional in addition to the
firing rate change with running speed
you have a change in theta with Missa
tee with running speed so theta
rhythmicity can be detected by doing on
auto correlogram so if you actually take
the spike train relative to itself and
they're firing about a Hertz then
they're going to start to line up as you
shift the line up again at 125 and then
250 milliseconds so these Peaks reflect
the eight Hertz periodicity of firing
and as the brats running at low speed
you have about eight Hertz periodicity
and then it'll actually you can see
these Peaks get closer together as the
periodicity
increases in frequency with higher
running speeds and this is shown in a
number of different cell types here so
it seems like there's actually two
different ways of coding the running
speed and they seem to be differentially
sensitive so when we when mark Brandon
did the medial septum and activation in
some cases he completely lost the
spatial about the theater with Missa T
of the spiking of the neurons but even
though they lost their theta rhythmicity
they would actually still show very
clear firing rate changes with running
speed in fact they actually show better
linear relationships to running speed
compared to more saturation here and in
cases where he had medial septum
inactivation but he didn't completely
wipe out theta rhythmicity the important
thing to show here is that again the the
firing rate changes running speed is
maintained but you actually see a change
in the relationship of the theta
rhythmicity to running speed here it's
getting higher frequency with Missa tee
with higher running speed here it does
not maintain that relationship so this
adjusts the interesting idea that maybe
the loss of the grid cell spatial
periodicity with medial septum and
activation is somehow due to a loss of
the speed modulation the spike with
spiking rhythmicity in these neurons
which is a potential role for theta
rhythmicity in the mechanism of grid
cell generation alright so and what I
wanted to mention that all of these
models require movement direction as
their input and they cite papers about
head direction but you may have already
kind of thought about the fact that head
Direction isn't necessarily movement
direction in the environment and we
explicitly just looked at this in a
paper we looked at the behavior of the
animals in the environment and showed
that the head Direction does not always
line up with the movement direction you
can imagine that as you're walking down
a street you can be looking to one side
or the other differentially for
different amounts of time and we
actually tested during periods where
they don't line up tested to see whether
cooked cells were coding head direction
or movement direction and found that
there were no cells that were purely
coding movement direction even though as
in previous studies many many cells show
coding of head direction and only a
small number show coding of head
direction and movement direction so that
really suggests the dominant code is for
head direction which is an interesting
question for these types of models why
is it that the head direction
predominantly encoded and I want to
emphasize both of the types of models I
described the attractor models and the
oscillatory interference model will show
great coding if you give movement
direction as input their coding will
break down if you give neurons coding
head direction as the input to the to
the model all right so this raises these
interesting questions what's the role of
theta rhythm in the generation in grid
cells and time cells and why is head
Direction coded more strongly than
movement direction and in some ways it
might seem obvious that maybe it's
because sensory input is more important
for coding of grid cells than path
integration is alright so now I want to
kind of go to this digression that I
added to talk about in relation to
Lauren Frank stated cuz it's really very
exciting to me this is something that I
actually we saw a number of years ago
and I was very interested specifically
in the possibility this sort of
trajectory retrieval so it's really
exciting to see what Lauren's shown I'm
not going to show you location
representations of different phases
we're gonna focus on head direction
representations but as Lauren mentioned
in the internal cortex initially Kate
Jeffery showed what she called theta
cycle skipping and then Sachin Deshmukh
and Jim canoe rims lab showed this and
then it's also been shown in the medial
septum this is you can see this with the
auto correlogram and you saw this in the
cross correlograms that Lauren showed if
you have a standard auto correlogram it
has a peak at 125 milliseconds
indicating a Hertz rhythmicity but if
you get this safe theta cycle skipping
of a small peak at 125 and then a larger
peak at 250 milliseconds indicating that
on average they're tending to fire every
other cycle and here's an example of
that where cells spiking on one cycle
then it's quiet for one thing a cycle
then it spikes and it's quiet than it
spikes so exactly what Lauren showed to
you but in our case we were primarily
seeing this in head Direction cells and
what we did was to look at different
head Direction cells in terms of their
cross correlations so we had two
examples of two theta skipping cells
shown by the auto correlogram and then
looked at the cross correlograms and
just as Lauren showed for 16% of the
cells here in this case these cells are
firing on the same cycle and then less
often on directly alternating cycles so
here you can see they're firing together
then they're off and they're together
but then just like Lauren showed and
this is real
marvelous the seed to see the
convergence of this data in cross
correlations of pairs so theta cycle
skipping pairs we saw examples just like
he saw where there was a zero cross
correlation at zero milliseconds and
then a nice strong cross correlation 125
milliseconds and then this is just an
example I mean it's not always this
clean but in this case you can see these
cells are firing you know green on one
cycle then blue then green and blue then
green and blue just like Lauren was
talking about so it's really a beautiful
Association but as I mentioned it's it's
primarily in head direction this is
recording in an trial court X rather
than hippocampus we didn't have that
many grid cells you know certainly not
recorded simultaneously so we couldn't
do the sequence prediction or the
sequence decoding but we could look at
the head Direction cells coding and you
can see when they're synchronous we
actually often saw many cells that
shared head direction tuning but for
these anti synchronous pairs we saw no
pairs that had head direction tuning
closer than 40 degrees from each other
now obviously they had to have some
overlap in their coding or they wouldn't
be spiking together all right
but what we saw was that cells that were
anti synchronous tend to have head
Direction coding that was further apart
and as Lauren beautifully showed they
you know with your angular velocity the
raft can't zip their head back and forth
the theta rhythm you know try that
you'll get a really painful neck do you
try to move your head that quickly and
even with the small heads they're not
doing that as he showed so it really
isn't that they're they're moving back
and forth between what it seems like is
that if they're you know in a particular
orientation where they could activate
two head directions they seem to maybe
be switching back and forth between
these two possible head directions and
potentially doing trajectory coding
though we don't know that from our own
data but Lorentz data suggests that so
this was very exciting to me because
actually earlier on I'd done simulations
where we done shown you know separation
of encoding and retrieval on different
dynamics and related to this discuss the
idea that encoding would be driven by
the current sensory input and the
retrieval would be on a different phase
of theta which which is necessary to get
nice clean representations to avoid the
sort of interference that Lorentz
actually shows can happen in these types
of models and so in this paper with
Howard I can bomb we actually talked
about how the retrieval could be
happening on a particular phase of theta
it also relates to work we did that
Marat airdam did in my laboratory where
we are showing how grid cell
representations could do trajectory
forward trajectory retrieval in multiple
different directions
to do kind of a giving a model based
sampling of potential trajectories for
goal locations similar to what David was
talking about alright so in the last
section I want to kind of get back to
talking about the potential cortical
century influences on grid cells and as
I already mentioned this this
predominance of head direction
selectivity in adrenal cortex suggests
and the important role of you know head
direction is important for determining
the angle of sensory input so there's a
lot of data indicating a role of visual
sensory input on grid cell firing so
initially kaswell Barry showed this
effect where if you move the barriers in
an environment it would actually cause a
compression of the spacing of grid cell
firing fields and then this was
replicated by the stance ULA's in the
Moser laboratory and they showed this
additional characteristic that different
grid cell modules seem to respond
differentially to barriers so in this
case they showed grid cells that had a
narrow spacing between the firing fields
usually recorded in more dorsal regions
actually didn't respond to the barrier
compression so these firing fields have
about the same distance even with the
border movement whereas grid cells and
more ventral regions with larger spacing
between the firing fields when they move
this barrier the environment to make the
environment smaller the actual spacing
between the grid cells compresses in
that direction so with Florian rowdies
we actually modeled how this could arise
from the angle of visual features or
optic flow and really you can do use
either thing for coding location you can
I made this movie with these random dots
just to show how easy it is to get a
sense of your location in the
environment just based on either optic
flow or feature angle and we looked at
the ground plane characteristics using
template map matching from the perón
technique or features on the walls
will feature angle and we showed that we
could separately simulate you know
obviously when your feet focusing on
features on the ground plane you don't
see an effect of the movement of the
walls consistent with the you know the
lack of the rescaling and these smaller
firing fields or smaller spacing firing
fields whereas when the spacing was
larger we modeled this as the the
network responding to the features on
the wall and when we move the walls then
we get compression of the spacing
between the firing fields and so it's
kind of intriguing because this is more
these neurons are more indoor so these
are more in ventral and if you think
about it this is being projected the
ground plane is going to be more
projected on the dorsal retina you know
walls will be more on the ventral retina
so it could be that there's some retina
toppy in the medial internal cortex
which I I've been scouring the
literature to see if it's in any of
Callaway's data heat there's tons of
visual areas on the dorsal surface but
unfortunately internal cortex is on the
side of the brain and they don't get
down there and to do the the intrinsic
imaging we're connected to this now the
fluorine had used his same techniques of
the optic flow to actually model B what
Neil Burgess proposed as allocentric
boundary cells Neil originally proposed
he's way back in 1996 based on
stretching of the environment or
compressing of the environment the
effects on play cells if the environment
has stretched play cells will often
expand and he proposed that this could
be due to boundary cells that are
responding to specific barriers in the
environment and many years later after
this very very clear prediction many
years later these cells were described
or there'd be cells that would respond
consistently to one allocentric boundary
in the environment in this case the west
wall is causing responses are here the
south wall is causing response and and
if they insert a wall you see responses
against that side of the inserted wall
you see the same response against the
edge of a tabletop and when they pull
the tables apart you see the response at
the gap between the tables so it
indicates that these boundary responses
could depend not only on you know a
clear visual wall but also can respond
to a drop-off that the animal knows is
essentially a boundary on its
environment so as I mentioned Florian
rowdies use the same
template matching for optic flow for it
to detect the boundary between the
ground plane and the wall or between a
ground plane and the distance wall when
there's a tabletop now Neal Burgess
really has been very prescient in his
descriptions of these networks because
he not only proposed these boundary
cells well before they were discovered
but he also proposed that they could he
didn't arise from an interaction of
egocentric representations of features
with head Direction cells and proposed
that they could converge in areas such
as retro spleen neocortex and so he was
proposing not only allocentric boundary
cells but also egocentric responses to
boundaries and plotted this in this
paper and more recently Jake Inman has
shown these egocentric boundary cells
that Neal Burgess predicted now
interestingly Jake Inman was recording
in the dorsal striatum we don't normally
record and striatum he was initially
aiming for lateral septum and hit dorsal
stratum and saw these very interesting
cells there but I mentioned in the
context of retro spleen neocortex
because now auntie alexandra in my lab
has shown them in retro style and he's
shown that they give the and we know
that the area of dorsal striatum is
actually receiving input from retro
spleen eon so this is almost examples of
these egocentric boundary cells they're
similar to something that Dorie dyrdek
Minh also described where when the rats
running around in the environment the
this particular cell is responding when
he was going east on the south wall and
when he's going west against the north
wall which if you think about it
corresponds to having a wall on the
right side the egocentric
right side of the animal which is
plotted here in polar coordinates where
that's front of the animal this is right
there's also cells that respond when the
wall is on the left side of the animal
so there's this coating of barriers
relative to animals egocentric
perspective and the way this is coded
here you can see that cells responding
with spikes under different barriers and
for each spike then Jake plotted the
location of the barrier and with
multiple barriers then you get a sense
so this is this cell is tending to
respond when there's a barrier at about
10 to 20 centimeters in the front right
of the animal and he because occupancy
normalization to see that across the the
occupancy and he can dissociate the
egocentric and the allocentric reference
frame so he also saw head Direction
cells in the stratum which have been
described by people such as cherie ms
amore and he showed that these
allocentric head Direction cells will
respond the based on the overall
environment even if he rotates the local
environment but when he rotates the
local environment by 45 degrees the
egocentric boundary cells maintain their
egocentric representations so the actual
responses will rotate with the
environment he also showed that the
responses are stable across multiple
different environments so it's not that
it's remapping the way play cells would
and he showed similar to what the
Burgess lab and others had shown here
you see a response for an egocentric
cell against a wall here's a response
for a tabletop so they seem to be
responding not just to simple visual
features but to the presence of a
barrier in the environment so this fits
very well with this framework that Neal
Burgess had proposed for this coating of
egocentric representations that could
create the allocentric representations
both of the boundaries and ultimately of
place in the environment alright so I
just wanted to kind of leave you with
some of these interesting questions we
still don't really know I think there
needs to be further modeling work even
with the attractor models to address how
theta rhythm is is influencing the
response characteristics in these
circuits why is head Direction coded
more strongly the movement direction and
how do neural circuits code position and
self motion from visual feature angle or
optic flow we've used relatively
abstracted models for that and I'd like
to see them be more biological and
finally I want to give credit to Jake
Inman who did the eccentric boundary
sell as a mark Brandon who did the work
on the medial septum and activation on
it Florian rowdies who did a lot of
modeling I talked about thanks
[Applause]
yeah we have thought about that and I
didn't mean to imply that there couldn't
be in fact I said sensory cues at the
beginning because it is very possible
especially for the egocentric boundary
cells that are responding quite close to
the animal that the whisker input could
be significant but there certainly were
cells are cells at responding to
barriers at 10 or 20 centimeters where
was beyond the range of the whiskers I
just so I didn't hadn't thought about
the head direction versus movement
direction thing it's incredibly striking
to me that everything falls apart when
you use the signal that's actually there
so I just do you have any ideas about
how that works because I'm at a complete
loss yeah I mean my best idea is really
that the animals are probably using it
that it's more important to know the
head direction translate the visual cues
from the you know retina topic
coordinates to allocentric coordinates
and then do what robotics is called
visual odometry to get running speed you
know to get speed and direction from the
the visual sensory inputs rather than a
proprioceptive input so if this were
true there should be difference between
the red moving around and dark and in
life like maybe this might be an
experimental prediction that if it's in
dark maybe it's the body Direction is
more dominant and yeah I mean the head
Direction cells will fire in darkness
still and and there's so but people and
people have not specifically tried to
find movement directions cells in the
darkness that's actually an interesting
point and and we have started to look
for movement Direction cells now to see
if they would show up
but if the brain was doing that
permutation then when you see a signal
like that put it that yeah you would
expect that you'd see that signal
somewhere and I mean when we actually
were trying to we can you know we
published this paper in a special issue
in brain research which is you know
that's where you know John Okeefe first
published grid cells but or play cells
but we brain research wasn't our first
journal of choice and that's kind of
exactly the you know argument the people
were making they were saying well these
movement Direction cells have to be
somewhere and you haven't proven that
they're not somewhere else and that's
very true
do you want to predict that maybe the
hit direction it's keeping its driving
the Thetis sequence skipping because the
directionality different segments and
the upcoming decision difference will
cause one two different directions
possible direction I'm thinking when you
predict it in a safe David radishes test
very wise to continue on the same path
but for different lengths yeah I mean
yeah I guess that would be an
interesting prediction I mean we were
recording in an open field environment
where there certainly were many options
for directions of going where's in his
test you're talking about different
lengths along the same circle track and
so you wouldn't necessarily
differentiate them so what you would
predict is that there ought to be a
systematic change maybe in head
direction as it's reading out a
trajectory that goes through this kind
of change and yeah so yeah so I think
you're right that and I have kind of
thought about the fact that yeah if
you're you know navigating in an
environment and making choices about
actions you need to know not you know
that there's a wall on your right so you
don't bonk your head into it we've all
experienced that so so I think that's a
good point at the functional role of
that output but in terms of the Neal
Burgess model you know I was thinking
more those are reflective of the input
from retro selenium
so the differential expansion of the
grids of different scales when the
environment is resized I think of that
result is also related to the result of
expansion of all grid fields and novel
enclosures and I was wondering if you
know whether in a novel enclosure
there's a differential expansion of the
vs. yeah so they didn't have as many
modules I mean that stencil a study was
very heroic in terms of getting you know
simultaneous recording of four different
modules and that the berry papers you
know the berry in addition to the
barrier movement they also did this in
novel environment that they owned they
never had more than two spatial scales
at one time and Caswell said they don't
see that differential compression even
in when they did the compression in
their in their manipulations so so
that's an interesting puzzle their
interpretation of that scaling effects
with with the boundary compression and
differences and especially something
Francesco savelii and I had written a
little bit about and there's a poster
from China and Russell Epstein's lab and
that's a family they do modeling where
they replicate that effect not by
actually compressing the grid what
happens is as the animal moves closer to
the wall which is not where he's
expected to do it causes a shift of the
grid as the boundary corrects the proper
phase of the grid if the amount that the
boundary went was more or less the same
period as a grid then there's no
Corrections be made
and it looks like it's fine but if the
scale is bigger and then when when when
it's 1/2 agreed shifts to correct its
phase it appears as if it's a
compression of the whole grid so there's
a he did this modeling which actually
seemed to the extent that I have a
poster look pretty decent so it's
actually an interesting plan I think
whether that effect really is
compressing the grid versus really just
being an indication of an
thought that these boundaries cells are
supposed to do is to actually be a way
to reset the face of the grid at Lisa
Giacomo of course you know yeah paper
kind of showing that so it's actually
their alternative yeah yeah yeah we
certainly this is just one hypothesis
there certainly that's very plausible
there you have that resetting okay well
we should probably move on we have a
break now and that measurement Lucinda
3:30
[Applause]